[Music]
Oh
I was looking forward to a perfect time
I knew the weather would be good you
know the beach was fantastic
the the hotel itself was wonderful I was
very very excited so you know I was
thinking all-inclusive stars looking
forward to the food we were looking
really forward to it I think Michael
should wear tall yes I'm and all of you
yeah polite holiday when we do it really
look forward to it like to live it oh
yeah hooyo sort of thing
I was still a bit wary because in the
Bardo attacks anyone else would be but
it was we were staying in a completely
different part of the country you know
we as we thought a bit safer more more
for tourists I thought that were just
miles away I thought well we're going to
be protected otherwise government 'add
sir it's an Al Gore - traveler I was
aware like everybody else of the prior
attack in my opinion had there been a
threat to travel then we wouldn't have
been travelling because something has
already happened there you would
naturally think that would be safe and
but when I discussed it with Ben Ben was
against the idea of going to Tunisia but
I managed to persuade him that it would
be ok it was a beautiful day and I
wanted to go to the beach so my husband
had already been down to put some towels
for us to sunbathe and I didn't want to
sit there
so I remember saying I can't sit here I
feel vulnerable and that's not something
I would generally say I don't know why I
said it but I knew I had to move because
it was my birthday back then it's
planned for me to go paragliding so he
booked me to do that but we got down to
the beach quite early so it was about
it's about 10:00 10:30 we got we got to
the beach so we went on Friday morning
we went down it with the Navarone when
she wants going to see songwriting just
say yeah every was in a high mode yeah
very friendly air a lot well mostly
English people really it was just just
happiness and just a really lovely
situation the gentleman on the beach
moved us back a few rows on the back row
onto the back row unfortunately the
first people to be shot were there I was
just reading my book you've gone for a
little dip in the water and that's where
no well I thought fireworks at you know
12 o'clock in the afternoon
then Sydney popping off you know that
give me a gun fire I thought I just
thought maybe it was I don't know
someone selling something on the beach
so I instantly sort of sat up and
started looking whoa
that was an explosion that I was like
once you realized what that mean you
know you hear them bands and fireworks
going off that's this thing a thought
and then say you're convinced it did the
Saltine me to the shorten assured I'm
telling ya this Alton I heard the
gunshot
my stomach was slurring I think I was
trying to compose myself for what was
about to happen and then atenism and run
towards me and he said get down and run
for your life
[Music]
Oh Mathias who lives in this cat guide
to see you Oh large American how did she
look I could see people sort of run them
but it's a weird feeling because
everything was in slow motion and
everything turned silent I didn't hear
anyone scream I just completely froze
and my brother said to me I'm sure that
was again I looked to the side of me and
that was when I could see the whole
Beach stampeding towards me so I then
turned and turned and ran towards Ben
all I could see was just a wave of
people and send beds and I obviously
sherry was down by the water so I had to
spot Charlie and then go out to the
engagement ring in the back as well so
to make sure I got that bag with me grab
Shelly and there was a lane that went
straight from our little beach area to
the hotel gate next thing you told us to
run open into this street we went to
fish shop I think your shutters were
down and already put up and shutters an
aunt in says so we caught go in there
and then we're on up to end shop look
quite a few wonders go up also 15 total
in that job yeah cause it bracket all
that as well why dr. Korb it's a
motorbike in and then you think wow fee
if it wasn't he if he comes in this shop
it's kind of a thing like it is a we
gone we're done everyone just started
running I lost my husband I don't know
what happened and my dad had had
geophones em I just remember screaming
run we need to run and grab in your hand
we were running towards our hotel and
the gates were you know the jar ready to
be closed I think they were just trying
to get as many people in as they could
and luckily our hotel was closed off in
Thai
people would just scream in and then I
started hearing the grenades going off
which was actually the wall at the side
of s and we come to a crossroad and I
honestly thought that's what we gonna
get ambushed
I really thought there's going to P be
people creating a distraction one end
and there was going to be other people
ready to kill us the other end I really
thought I was gonna die when I got my
bearings and looked around I could see
my husband was struggling and he told me
to go ahead with the children as a man
as a parent you know that's what you
have to do and we were all in a narrow
area and we were all and boiling hot
concrete my son was terrified I had
stopped I could see the blood on the
floor from my feet and then I can hear
more gunfire and grenades I honestly
thought at that point that we were all
going to die and we made the choice to
stay together it's like you see this on
telly you don't you know you don't you
can't imagine I'm on holiday I'm on
holiday what I've told my family on
holiday I'm guilty affecting my family
holiday and I'm a oh yeah and then we're
going to law I'm going to laws we're
going to we're not going to be here you
know yet the things like say you're
shaking you're running you're that
scared you the thoughts like you think
I've got to protect I've got to protect
you could hear gunshots like at backers
and you could hear them like at both
sides it felt like we were walking in
middle they told to go back to our rooms
after watching the news we had bit of an
idea there was a bad situation we locked
herself in the room and my son turned on
his phone and locked at Twitter and when
we locked there were bodies everywhere
at this point there was army helicopters
flying around you could see the army on
at the beach so yeah I kind of felt safe
knowing that those yeah there was
someone there to help we decided that we
would take mattresses off the bed and
barricade ourselves in we couldn't leave
the hotel it was impossible it was too
much of a danger just had a call from
the office a few moments ago we are
going to put it on lights for you this
evening go back to the UK okay please be
sad that we've always really never want
to do this and I don't want to repeat
myself no no I'll take questions of the
animal
we just wanted to get home then neither
when you're on the coach it was pitch
black and you going through the desert
and but that was not nice going source
out there you know just I thought
petrified seamen just sitting on the
plane I knew I was going home I knew I
was going home to my family but still I
just you know you hear about things I
plan on planes that these things happen
and so I just did not feel safe right I
just I needed to be with my family and
back back home in you know in my my
safety
oh yeah I scared the minute we landed I
felt I could breathe I felt that I had
held my breath for 24 hours just
fighting to every move I make now and
it's just it's completely changed our
lives all together as Annette sometimes
a lot DARS and walk up stairs and turn
and I think he's gonna come and get me I
think is gonna come and get me grab my
legs and yeah do me kill me and family
you know you get the these are somewhat
thoughts and then your your work upon
and I sweating shaking read enough
recaps I know what proper nightmares are
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know whether it could have been
prevented
because when that man woke up that
morning he knew what he was going to do
and he didn't care how we did it or who
we there the stated I don't know if
there was been more security on the
beach whether that would have helped
there was so many people that were their
lives have been torn apart from from
this one day and just finding out
exactly what why that happens and and
hopefully what just some sort of closure
for the families I think yeah definitely
closure for the families of course all
we did were guilty we known holiday
relaxing working people the
thirty-eighth never come back and I feel
so sorry for them I came home with my
family and I was lucky for those people
there has to be some justice I know it
don't change the outcome
[Music]
you